[Applause]
possible to start immediately everybody
knows our friend the former member of
this Parliament for this year the Prime
Minister Latia thank you thank you can
infer for stay with us for accepting our
invitation for this important debate on
the future of the European Union you are
at home today you know very well dis
Parliament the debate with you will be
very easy you know very well the
position of the European Parliament the
importance of the European Parliament
you know the President of the European
Commission the vice-president of the
European Commission thank you for coming
as you know for us day we want the
European Parliament at the center of the
political debate on the future of the
European Union you are member Adan orem
of this Parliament for this welcome and
we have immediately the floor thank you
very much a pathologist Russian editor
on the electronic recording system for
the catch the eye is in procedure is
open I'll close it after a prime
minister currency speech
Ochs the guava taste the honey comes
dear president Ayane dear president
Younker dear members of parliament
ladies and gentlemen friends first of
all I am very glad to address you on
this very important issue the future of
Europe as you know very well for nearly
10 years I worked in the Parliament as a
parliament member and I have managed to
learn a few things during this period
it's just one been mantilla a narrator
gave mr. Mossman if you want to speak in
this house you need to know at least
three languages fluently otherwise it
just doesn't work so this is a time for
languages it's too hard for me to speak
French unfortunately I do understand
languages but for a full speech that
would be asking a little bit too much in
English now oh this is language for it's
a change the end of the term the coming
of the elections it really is a time for
reflection but before we look forward I
want to go a little bit back in history
to give a little bit of context so
Latvia
Europe what binds Europeans really when
you think about it it is the shared
history coming from ancient Greece and
Rome through Christianity Christianity
that spread throughout Europe and as
Christianity in this culture had spread
throughout Europe the last remaining
outpost were the Baltics that still had
not become part shall we say of this
common shared cultural and religious
heritage it was only in the the turn of
the 12th and 13th century that the Pope
in Rome said okay to a crusade against
the non-christians in the Baltics since
that time our country went through all
of the cultural development changes
upheavals that the rest of Europe went
through whether it's the Renaissance the
Reformation the Enlightenment today our
country is predominantly at least
historically a Lutheran country strong
Catholicism in the South in the south
east we view ourselves and through our
history you are part of the the Northern
European cultural area is very clear
with yourselves as being rather
pragmatic very patient we'd like to
think rational and law-abiding as well
and in the culture there's a strong
creativity on personal enterprise that
always presses its way through now for
hundreds of years after the introduction
of Christianity our country faced
various political and military overrule
coming at times from Germany at times
from Poland at times from Sweden and at
times from Russia throughout this time
of course we maintained our identity or
language and culture and it was not
until the end of the First World War
in 1918 that we finally declared our own
independence and it took two more years
for the war of independence
to free the country of the remaining
German in the Russian armies which was
still there at the time as if you went
to personal family history my father's
father my grandfather he entered the
Czarist army as a soldier for the Tsar
then he became a Bolshevik soldier
fighting the revolution against the Tsar
and then when his unit heard that our
country had declared independence he
came home and became a freedom fighter
for independence
a typical history at the time our
country developed between the wars then
the Second World War came it did a lot
of damage throughout Europe that's where
I come into the picture I am the son of
refugees wartime refugees my parents
they were children
in 1944 mother was eight father was 14
they fled in small boats from Latvia to
Sweden about five thousand Latvians came
to Sweden about two hundred thousand
fled to Germany as the advancing Soviet
Army was coming a second time
devastating the country my parents grew
up in Sweden met and married then they
emigrated further to the US where I was
born together with my two sisters I
first came to Latvia in 1984 at the time
I was a high school student in the last
refugee school the Latvian the refugee
high school that was in Minster in
Germany that's when I first came to
Latvia it was a different world a
different country everything was gray
people didn't smile on the streets
Soviet soldiers on leave but everywhere
everything was in Russian you could see
a visible lack of investment in any kind
of infrastructure whether they were
buildings or roads or bridges you could
see decay
as solidarity came in the late 1980s in
Poland and the Berlin Wall fell in the
end of 1989 change happened in our
country as well we finally regained
independence in 1991 and in a very short
amount of time we developed democratic
institutions we developed free
enterprise we developed a banking system
we developed a market economy basically
from scratch and in 2004 it was only 13
years after regaining independence we
joined the EU and NATO in a couple of
weeks time we're going to celebrate 15
years since we joined the European Union
and I can say on behalf of my country we
have not regretted a single day since we
joined the EU so what what is what is
the EU well first of all and it must be
stressed it is the union of values
freedom democracy the rule of law
historically in Europe power disputes
settled with soldiers with guns with
rifles with tanks with destruction how
do we do it today
tiresome debate discussion votes but
it's a heck of a lot better than the way
it was done before the EU is also about
economic development and at the core of
that is the single market by opening up
our borders to one another we have
created one of the largest markets in
the world over 500 million people in
sheer economic size roughly equivalent
to the United States which is considered
the world's most strongest economy but
all is really not well in the EU
all of us know as politicians that
there's a lot of anti-eu sentiment going
around there are politicians who are
offering very simplistic answers to very
complex issues generally we refer to
they're referred to as populist my
simple message is don't fight the
populist it's a worthless endeavor but
try to understand why are people
listening to the populist why are people
unhappy so why are people unhappy what
happened go back 10 years 2008 2009 a
bank collapsed in the u.s. okay they
collapse every once in a while that led
into a chain reaction of a banking
crisis around the world especially in
Europe that led to an economic crisis
the biggest since we had since the Great
Depression
my own country's GDP fell by almost
one-quarter one of the big steepest
drops in about a year and a half
other countries fell as well maybe not
so badly and as we're coming out of the
epic economic crisis what happened a few
years ago the migration crisis the
unrest in the Middle East it started as
peaceful revolutions that turn into
bloody revolutions and then refugees
migrants the result of all of that is
what I would call a political crisis
people losing faith in the system it's
understandable that they've lost faith
we have to help them regain it so when
you think if you look at voters what are
their main concerns I say there are four
jobs the way of life translated into
immigration the environment and safety
and security to talk about the future of
Europe you need to address all these
four issues so what about jobs the EU
has a mechanism to foster job growth and
it is that which is simply referred to
as the single market I think of a of a
story I remember as a child I think it
may have been one of Aesop's fables
father has three sons and he gives the
stick to one of his sons and says break
this stick and the Sun breaks the stick
and then he gives another stick to the
Sun his brakes is thickened the Sun
breaks the stick and he says well what's
the difficulty then he gives the son a
whole bundle of sticks together he says
now break the stick and he tries he
tries he can't gives it to your brother
can't third brother can't the simple
moral of the story is when you're alone
you can be broken easily like a stick
like a twig when you're united you're
powerful and that is the beauty of the
single market now we have challenges to
the single market coming from the
outside there's a rising China and
there's a u.s. whose administration
seems to be faltering a little bit in
its belief that it has a leading in a
major role to play in organizing world
affairs and world trade now what about
China a country that openly subsidizes
its huge industries and these industries
are coming into Europe competing really
on an unfair advantage at the same time
European companies don't have equal
access to Chinese markets what's the
answer I say the answer to unfair
competition is not protectionism
we cannot go the way of the Chinese we
should not become more like the Chinese
but demand that the Chinese become more
like us in terms of opening up their
market we have a lot of clout as a union
and as a single market this is what we
need to use but not as individual sticks
but as that bundle that cannot be broken
and can change things in the world
inside the EU we still have hurdles to
overcome and this has to do with the
internal barriers still to the single
market both especially I should say in
the digital sphere as well as in a
services sphere I asked myself ask
yourself why are the largest Internet
companies coming from the US why aren't
the European
I think the answer is pretty obvious the
US has $1 own it has a federal
government in the federal budget and it
has zero barriers between the states in
terms of trade they have a truly United
single market smaller than now is 330
million we have a larger one but we have
too many hurdles so if we talk of
wanting to have national champions I
don't think that we should bend our
competition laws to artificially create
national champions I think we have to
tear down the barriers within the single
market to let those champions grow
themselves and they can take on the
world they can take on the US and they
can easily take on China now one of the
cornerstones of the single market is the
financial system the banks ten years ago
the biggest threat to the banks was
liquidity so we created a banking union
to make sure that the ECB is overseeing
the largest banks - to make it more safe
that the banks will really be there
tomorrow morning when we wake up the
world has changed since those ten years
liquidity is not the main problem a new
problem is emerged which is terrorism in
Europe and the financing of terrorism
and how does that often happen through
illicit funds moving through the
European banking system so where are we
on anti money laundering in in this
house I was the co reporter with Miss
Argentine II on the the last two AML
directives learned a thing or two about
policy AML is anti money laundering
legislations all about risk assessment
and reducing the risk of dirty money
entering the system
the east of Europe we have a country a
big economy Russia and for years for the
past 20 years money from Russia has been
wanting to flee that country why because
Europe is safe Europe has the rule of
law Europe no one takes your money away
without going through the courts you
can't do that that money wants to come
to Europe some of it is clean maybe most
of it is clean but some of it is not
clean and those who are working with
unclean money the criminals I'm not
talking about people looking to optimize
their tax returns and itemizing is this
an expense or not I'm talking about
hardened criminals that are moving
millions of euros they're flying like
hawks above the ground and they're
looking at the chain the weak links in
the chain in this country you can do
that in this country you can do that in
this country you can do that our country
was also part of this chain not alone
money laundering is a European problem
now since becoming Prime Minister I
don't have the patience to wait for all
of us to get our act together so I'm
cleaning up my house we're going to have
the cleanest and the most resilient
banking system in Europe in 1/2 years
time we'll gladly consult anyone in this
room and in this house on how to clean
up a banking system but it's a little
bit like fighting rats I can make sure
that I get the rats out of my house and
my house will be clean but what about my
neighbours the criminals may have left
Latvia for now but they have
unfortunately I'm convinced not left
Europe so we have to clean the whole
neighborhood that means AML supervision
anti-money laundering supervision has to
be centralized just as Prudential
supervision very strong an important
step forward
so another concern about the voters
immigration the way of life there are no
simple answers here I don't have them I
don't think anyone does the truth is
Europe is the fantastic destination to
come to live to work we have stable
economies we have stable democracies we
have the rule of law we have individual
freedom and a lot of our neighbors do
not and as autocracy grows the pressure
on wanting to come into the EU will only
increase it will not go away so we have
to learn to deal with it my country
dealt with a little bit of immigration
as well during the 50 years of Soviet
occupation more than 700,000 people
migrants arrived in our country that's
one third of the population were only 2
million 700 thousand came in our
government had no say over this because
we had no government it was Moscow
making the decisions fully making the
decisions no Co decision no say after
regaining independence how have we dealt
with it with the one big I word
integration you have to work with the
people you have to work on your
educational system bring the people into
our culture bring the immigrants into
your cultures this is the way forward we
cannot fight that you cannot stop people
wanting to come into Europe we are a
preferred destination but we have to
work on integrating these people but we
can do something to mitigate the flows
and the obvious answer to that is the
outer border frontex
this is a wonderful program needs to be
strengthened because if we can show our
voters that we control the outer border
then we can have free inner borders and
we won't have the situation of a few
years ago where within the Schengen zone
we remember going between Strasbourg and
in Germany those of us who stayed in
hotels
that the bridge is sometimes closed or
they're checking every car this is not
the way forward we need open internal
borders for a single market to work
which means we need firm borders on the
outside we will have to fund refugee
camps it's inevitable we will have to
fund development of economies in the
rule of law in third countries this is
inevitable and we have to work on
integration Europe is a union of 28
still sovereign countries with their own
national identities it's extremely
important that we maintain our national
identities cultures and languages and we
do this through the process of
integration of people who have come in
the arrivals they have to adapt to our
countries because that's the way of the
world and this is what we need to work
on if we can show that we control the
outer borders and we can integrate the
arrivals the voters will become much
more relaxed about the entire issue
third concern environment climate change
I don't I won't go into it deeply it's
real mankind coal oil and gas burning is
contributing we need to stop this so the
legislation the direction is absolutely
correct reduce co2 emissions increase in
rubles increase energy efficiency all of
this has to be done but we have a
difficulty is that not all member states
have the same kind of energy mix my own
country is just behind Sweden we are
almost 40% of renewables we're way ahead
of the curve but not everyone is ahead
of the curve that way some countries are
very cold dependent and we cannot just
wish fossil fuels away someone has to
pay for the transition so we need a
little bit of time now regardless of
of how quickly we want to move there's
one structural change that we need to
make to make that change faster and that
is again I'm a single market kind of
person opening up the market in energy
to competition you have to have
competition for renewables to advance
I'll just take one example the
electricity market many countries have
regulated electricity prices consumers
pay the same Monday morning Monday
evening Monday night Sunday morning
Sunday evening Sunday night so no one is
motivated to think about when to turn on
the dishwasher the clothes washer or you
know it doesn't matter you pay the same
all the time so I'm not motivated to
save but in those markets where
competition has been opened up you have
service providers that help you
automatically regulate when you're
buying electricity based upon the price
signals and in this way we can reduce
the overall needed capacity to supply
the demand peak hours because during the
peak hours you will be motivated not to
use say or have your refrigerator go
warmer by one or two degrees if you
could do that for millions of households
the savings are enormous but you have to
have deregulated markets if you want
renewables you have to have deregulated
markets
competition everywhere and the fourth
concern safety and security it means
different things to different Europeans
I think in the south of Europe when
people think of safety and security
people are thinking about the threat of
uncontrolled immigration migration
terrorism that's another threat that
people feel in the west of Europe maybe
the biggest threat right now is of an
uncontrolled bricks it not only for
trade but also for peace in Northern
Ireland a very very real concern
I come from Latvia and it's no secret to
anyone that when Latvians think of
safety we think of Russia Russia is our
eastern neighbor to all of Europe Russia
has a government that has one basic
policy it feels and it is convinced and
it is in their policy paper
that they are surrounded by enemies
always under attack that is their dogma
that is their belief so the way that
they fight back is to make their enemies
weaker right now in Europe the biggest
threat from Russia is not military it's
a threat but it's not the biggest threat
we have NATO we have our own
preparedness the biggest threat is the
threat of false and misleading and
downright lying information we live we
live in the world of these wonderful
devices that all of us have in our
pockets or on our desks I thought as
many of us did a few years ago that this
information is the age of having
unlimited access to knowledge to facts
you know preparing a speech you can go
into the internet and find all kinds of
crazy good things but it also turns out
that social media is a fantastic way to
disseminate propaganda and downright
lies instantaneously and it's more and
more people move away from getting their
news from the mass media from educated
journalists that have a certain ethic in
checking their their sources as more and
more people are getting the news from
social media we have to do one important
thing is to think seriously about
legislating the responsibility of
platforms providers on the Internet of
the content that is being disseminated
it's a slippery slope I admit because
it's a fine line between looking for
responsibility and introducing a
censorship as a Latvian I will never
support censorship too much history
there but we have to find that fine line
because this is an attack on our way of
life what are they looking to do to
divide society to make us fight one
another to make us dislike one another
think of the debate vaccination where in
the world does this argument come from
that vaccination leads to autism you can
trace it back to the Russian outlets
they're disseminating this they're
making people not be vaccinated in its
resulting in very serious health
repercussions throughout Europe
immigration the immigration debate
behind that also Russia brexit very
involved we even have this bubble
throughout all the east of Europe of
George Soros is some terrible person
who's undermining our way of life
somehow we're being told it all comes
from one single source and if we do not
accept that fact we cannot begin to
address it but I say for safety and
security militarily my country invests
two percent of its GDP into the military
we're part of NATO we think everyone
should be doing this but military is one
part of the equation the second part
equally important is combating the
dissemination of false and misleading
information and there we have to
consider legislation so finally I
wouldn't be a Latvian politician if I
didn't mention these a couple things
about the MFF the multi-annual financial
framework the seven-year budget that all
of us are in the midst of trying to come
to terms with
I completely agree and as this
Parliament does that we need to invest
in Europe more in research and
development into the clever young minds
that are going to really create the jobs
and the growth in value and in wealth in
the future this is extremely important
but it's equally important that as we're
investing into the R&D we don't just do
it in one two or five select capitals
but it moves throughout Europe why
clever minds are everywhere in Europe
everywhere in Europe needs growth if we
think of excellence only concentrated in
a few countries we actually do ourselves
a disservice
so yes into R&D but it really has to go
around Europe very important clever Oh
cohesion cohesion is still important but
it has to be clever we have to make sure
that the poorer regions are converging
upwards a very important aspect of that
and last but not least of this the
farmers in Europe we know that
historically the European budget has
been all about the cap it was you know
years back it's still important
but as a reminder and we have the
historic chance to write a historic
injustice all farmers in Europe compete
in the same market so if you sell grain
if you sell whatever you sell it on the
market the price is what the market
gives you
we subsidized through direct payments
our farmers in Europe but there's a
catch we don't subsidize our farmers
equally or even close to equally and the
three countries that are at the lowest
end of the pile well below the average
of the three Baltic countries Latvia
Lithuania and Estonia for up to
mathematical reasons dating to the 1990s
our farmers are competing with everyone
else's farmers the only way that they
can compete is at the cost of their own
well-being they are forced to be poor to
compete in the same market so if we
subsidized and I'm open to not
subsidizing anyone but I don't think
we'll get there in the next seven years
if we subsidized we should do it equally
across the board for everyone my speech
comes to an end
you can breathe easier friends the EU is
not and never will be perfect it's not
best damn thing that I can think of in
Europe for hundreds really thousands of
years differences were settled through
the force of muscle who was stronger
persevered who is weaker tough luck no
the way that we work is by far better
than anything that anyone has come up to
today member states have joined of their
own free will and with the consent of
their citizens member states can leave
the EU but we see in brexit actually
none of us realized how difficult that
would be but it's a testament to how
Europe works and also as a member of
Council I can say that the goodwill and
the you the the unanimous position the
sticking together
of the remaining EU 27 is a testament
that we can get through difficult times
through discussion through debate
sometimes very long debate without
resorting to any kind of violence and
this is the key to how the EU works that
we talk with one another not fight one
another so what about the future
to sum up I say we need to strengthen
the basics strengthen the single market
tear down the barriers control our outer
borders bring down the threat of
uncontrolled immigration have a clever
transition to clean energy bringing in
more market forces to play and focus on
our common security not only through the
military but also through the security
of the information information world
that we live in don't fight the populist
dress the causes of people's malcontent
left alone we're like Aesop sticks
we're just individual sticks and we can
be broken one by one even the large
European countries are small in the
world but United ask that bundle of
sticks the European Union is a major
force in the world and we can bring our
core values freedom democracy and the
rule of law to take bearing on other
countries thank you very much
[Applause]
Christianity are very popular in this
Parliament thank you and now the
president of European Commission
jean-claude juncker
dodong president Prime Minister ladies
and gentlemen members of the European
Parliament I am delighted to be here
together with the Prime Minister of
Latvia who is very familiar with this
chamber of course since for nine years
he had a seat in this chamber I'm
particularly delighted to see him
because I remember the very first
Latvian presidency in the Council of
Ministers I remember it because this was
the first real presidency of this
commission we actually coexisted for two
months together with the Italian
presidency and I remember it well I
remember in particular the very last day
of the Latvian presidency because that
was the ninth from the 29th to the 30th
of June and in that night we adopted our
directive our directive on free access
without discrimination to the Internet
you may remember that directive was
adopted then and that proves that you
need to be patient in Europe
you need to stay patient stay patient
until the very last day very often we
have discussions about brexit as if we
had nothing else to do before the
elections maybe it would be advisable to
draw citizens attention to the
performances that we have been able to
achieve over the last few years in
particular the useful decision that we
took on roaming yes drugs it is
important but the day-to-day lives of
our citizens
is more important we have seen a
commission of dialogue we have been a
commission of dialogue we have organized
a number of meetings with citizens 1,600
citizens dialogues all together
which goes to prove that the Commission
is not locked up in so kind of Balam or
bunker but actually is present
throughout the whole of Europe so it
goes to show that the Commission is not
about a
ultimate crew based arrangement on the
contrary we have day-to-day contacts
with our citizens in Europe Europe of
course cannot be built against the will
of the people's it cannot be built
without the nations nations are
important those who think that nations
are provisional sort of invention of
history are wrong
nations are present and are here to stay
and therefore as I see it we should not
talk about the United States of Europe
anymore because that actually gives the
impression that the European Union is
becoming a state more and more the
European Union will never be a state
like the United States of America never
we want to be Latvians Germans Bavarians
bretons French Luxembourgish but we also
are Europeans and there is no
contradiction between patriotism
responsible patriotism and a sense of
belonging to a larger entity namely the
European Union we in the Commission have
sought to avoid interference in minor
details of the day-to-day lives of our
citizens to steer clear of that and to
focus instead on the big issues on the
horizon for the future that was if you
like the contract reached by you and the
Commission you as the elected
representatives of the peoples of Europe
in July 2014 you may remember that I
outlined the major political priorities
of our commission and those were not
empty words in fact may 2018 you may
remember that we presented all the
proposals all the initiatives that we
had already flagged in 2014 and to this
very day we see that 350 of our
proposals have been adopted a hundred
and sixty-four are still on the table of
the co legislators still pending and
these have to do with important reforms
for instance asylum I would have liked
to have seen the adoption of all the
directives that have to do with that
particular subject matter and the reform
of our Asylum
system nevertheless I welcome the fact
that in the parliamentary history of
Europe never before have we seen so much
progress made in Social Affairs the
social area it has to be said for many
years was the poor relation when it came
to the building of Europe brought along
but this has changed and I'd like to
thank members of the European Parliament
thank you for being by our side for
showing determination for showing
conviction in order to achieve this
together with the Commission language
number two now mr. president Latvia is a
country that knows better than most what
it takes and what this worth to be part
of our union the Prime Minister made
this clear in his excellent speech few
moments ago here our country with the
Prime Minister that has always taken its
destiny into its own hands you have
lived up to the words of one of your
famous poets who are saying we will be
as great as our will and you are because
your will is well you have thought for
your freedoms in difficult circumstances
by far more difficult than the Western
Europeans can ever imagine you have made
history instead of being the victims of
is to be imposed by one of your biggest
neighbors
you have said no to the guns and to the
tanks and you have fought for your
liberty for your freedom and it's one of
the best events in recent history that
Latvia and others have gained freedom
and have fought for their place in the
south the place of Latvia was not in the
dark and in the shadow the place of
Latvia is a place of DISA in the Sun and
we are happy that you have joined the
European Union and not a single day did
we will get that Latvia became a member
of upu we have joined the Schengen area
and I fully agree with what you said
about internal borders and the
protection of external borders the
Commission has proposed coast guards and
border guards of 10,000 people men and
women the council was postponing this
to 2027 whereas the Commission had
proposed 2020 but everyone is saying we
have to protect our external boards
let's do it two proposals out of the
table you are helping to make Europe
stronger and safer you are one of the 25
member states that launched permanent
structure cooperation on defense matters
in December 2070 and I'm delighted that
you are playing a full role in a number
of European projects from making
cross-border military mobility easier
that's important for Latvia military
mobility you are making cross-border
military
mobility easier and you are countering
the threat of sea bites into it so you
have become the embodiment and living
proof of how Europe enhances national
serenity and influence take energy you
are mentioned in this very important
dimension of European policy your
history and your geography meant that
Latvia and the Baltics was an isolated
energy island cut off from the rest of
Europe when we took office we made it
clear that the European Union will never
leave its citizens out in the cold and
will never leave a member state in the
dark for me this was a Baltic issue yes
but not only about the issue
it was a European one this is why when
we took office we created an energy
Union and made it a top priority to
provide Latvia and its Baltic neighbours
with the stable secure and cheaper
energy they need today we are well on
the way to thank synchronising the
Baltic electricity grid with the rest of
Europe by 2025 we are investing in
infrastructure and we now have the
world's most ambitious and advanced
climate and energy frame back
I'm delighted that we turned the energy
on envision into reality and I thank you
and grateful to the Prime Minister
for his leadership and work as a member
of this Parliament and as a Prime
Minister today a president in German
president I chose I choose to speak
German Latvia is putting its full weight
behind Europe contributing with full
force and that's why it's perfectly
understandable for Europe to do the same
vice-versa to invest in Latvia is to
invest in the future of the European
Union Latvians know from firsthand
experience what kind of impact that can
have 50,000 jobseekers from Latvia who
have been coming since 2014
thanks to European resources have been
receiving new qualifications in order to
be able to operate on the labour market
300 kilometres of new roads once again
funded by EU resources and that is a
contribution to Riga being an economic
center a hub for the neighboring
countries and for better connections
with Estonia in particular 960 million
in terms of investments which have been
possible thanks to the so-called Younker
fund money mobilized in Latvia as for
the future of Latvia I think that that
future is a future that concerns us all
and that is why we would like to
couldn't suggest that in the next budget
a hundred billion euros be earmarked for
research and innovation investment into
research and innovation because we want
to meet the great challenges that lie
ahead for all of us together as a team
by way of an example we'll be looking at
financing for stronger borders for
better security multiplying that by 3 we
also want to make sure that in our
budget we give due consideration to
climate protection and we also want to
make sure that erasmus+ programme that
an increase is seen there 30 million
program euros sorry being earmarked for
that purpose - i would like to thank the
prime minister
his government for the support enduring
support helping us pave the way for
these new measures in the future I would
like to thank him I would also like to
maybe respond to your comments
concerning the MFF and our planning for
the future in financial terms you're
right you're right
that innovation research youth defense
these are areas that we need to invest
in of course but we're only in a
position to do that
if existing policies are also of course
they've got it
agriculture matters and cohesion
unfortunately sometimes we will have to
shift resources I'm not happy about that
but I know and this Parliament knows too
that there are certain priorities that
we need to fund and we can't you know we
can't break the EU budget nobody wants
to do that now I know of course that
Europe is worth much more than the 1.4
percent that we have been talking about
in terms of GDP it's worth much more
than that
but even the parliament when it comes to
budgetary issues you know it's been
perhaps less reticent than the the
council but still it has set a ceiling
an upper limit for the EU budget 1.3
percent was the figure that was agreed
by this Parliament so we the Commission
wanted 1.4 rather than 1.1 if we had
suggested that to begin with that I
don't think even you would have agreed
to that and many people in this house
would not have agreed to that either
what I'm trying to say is that you need
to set priorities but you shouldn't for
that reason sacrifice other policies
agriculture and cohesion are very
important and for some countries
particularly important Latvia how some
has experienced some difficult years not
just because of its geographical
location not just because of its
historical burden if you like the
history that precedes the present but
also for economic reasons Latvia
unfortunately was hard hit by the
economic crisis but five years five
years after the beginning of our mandate
I have to say five years down the road
the Latvian economy is doing
a lot better than before well on the
mend and I think that that is something
that we can also thank your predecessor
for rowdies Komorowski we can thank that
administration because Latvia was
brought back on track by that
administration and I have to say I made
efforts and I know that there have been
you know I've been successful in that
regard the vice president of the
Commission responsible for the Euro and
responsive for the social dialogue I
would like to thank you very much indeed
Commissioner for that work as I'm if you
diffuse I know when I was listening to
your statement I had a lot of things
that sprang to mind but you spoke for
such a long time that I'm afraid I'm
running out of my speaking time Latvia
is a small country by all means that may
be so I'm actually specialists when it
comes to small countries as it happens
but although it's small it's a country
with large ambitions big ambitions and
if you like you know we're talking about
a point where east and west meet and
east and west shall not be divided east
and west are if you like the two lungs
of the European Union and we want to
Europe with a good future and if we want
to Europe with a good future we have to
breathe with both lungs with both sides
this is in fact the last address that I
shall be making to this Parliament and I
do it with a heavy heart I see that some
colleagues and we'll be withdrawing from
politics or from this Parliament I must
say I have very much enjoyed my work
here I've learnt a lot I've also argued
a lot but nevertheless I think we have
achieved quite a lot as well it's a bit
like on the very first day when I first
took up office Europe is something you
have to love if you don't love Europe
then you're not capable of doing
anything for it I love Europe long live
Europe
[Applause]
merci beaucoup Monsieur president
recommission a symbol Thank You
president of the Commission thank you
jean-claude thank you for the excellent
cooperation although there have been
times where we've had differences of
opinion but the debate that's the work
between the Commission and the
Parliament is a very important
relationship and we're all